Did you get those three slopes right? If you did, great job. For the first
equation, we have y equals 3x plus 9. This equation is in slope-intercept form.
For slope-intercept form, we know the equation is y equals mx plus b, where b
is the y intercept and m is the slope. So, we know if the equation is in
slope-intercept form. The coefficient to the x variable is going to be the
slope. So in this case, the slope is equal to 3. The second equation is written
in standard form, 3x plus 2y equals 7. I find, putting the equation in slope
intercept form the easiest way to find the slope of an equation that is in
standard form. It just takes two simple steps. The first step is to subtract 3x
from both sides. When I subtract 3x from both sides, I get 2y equals negative
3x plus 7. I'm almost in slope intercept form but I have 2y instead of y
equals. So I have to divide everything through by 2. When I divide everything
through by 2, I get y equals negative 3 over 2 is negative 3 halves x, plus 7
halves. So once again, this equation is in slope-intercept form, so we know the
coefficient of the x variable, which is negative 3 halves, is the slope. So the
slope is negative 3 halves. The third practice problem was just a little bit
trickier. To get this equation in slope intercept form, I subtract 6x from both
sides and I get negative 3y is equal to negative 6x plus 12. Now, here's where
I have to be careful. I have to divide the whole equation through by negative
3. This can be a little confusing, but let's just take it one step at a time.
On the left side of the equation, I have negative 3 over negative 3, which of
course is 1. So that just leaves me with y. When I divide negative 6x by
negative 3, negative 6 divided by negative 3 is 2x. And then, I have 12 divided
by negative 3. 12 divided by negative 3 is negative 4. So now we have the
equation and slope intercept form, and the slope is going to be the coefficient
of the x variable, which is 2. If you got these answers correct, great job. If
not, you might want to go back and review the videos on how to find slope from
the equation of a line.